hello reject nation my name is greg i'm
john coy we are here to watch miss
marvel episode five today kamala koi's
exact words were it's episode five this
is when it gets crazy let's see if
you're right i did say that it's the
penultimate episode follow coy on tick
tock that's the only reason he's here is
to get followers there apparently does
some awesome theory videos and breakdown
of news over there it's an hour long ad
for a 30 second video this is
all the promo code why are we here
guys leave a like that would be very
much appreciated subscribe and click
that notification bell to see more of
john's face full length watch along to
recycle but the time code are available
for super sexy rejects over at our
patreon page thank you all who have
joined and showed your support it means
the world to us
also uh then prepper teams
people yup that's non-gendering uh guys
you guys awesome also uh we
upload our reviews and
commentary track stuff to to our
podcasts i'm we're doing this we're
doing great doing this
we got the introductory podcast vote for
your favorite intro of the season we've
killed it we've killed it and we're
gonna we're gonna watch
[Music]
interesting
period piece let's do it something's
wrong with disney plus tall
monochromatic
bloody trains arrive to their
destinations as homes are torched across
the country to understand how all this
began we must go back to a pivotal
moment in the indian struggle for
independence back in 1942
okay but how does this connect to the
marvel cinematic universe
are there easter eggs
that was really beautiful i'm glad they
told that story
[Music]
cool
we likey we haven't met her yet right
[Music]
this is some serious [ __ ] damn
[Music]
away
[Music]
these snotty brits that's right i hope
the uk audience is watching he said it
and i hope you feel real good about
yourselves
still just one bangle there's a
food and a place to rest if you need to
use my cottage
if she was ugly would he offer the same
thing he'd offer even more
their pants look so comfortable
we can have you culturally appropriate
them if you're same with americans
do you know when i saw you out there
it reminded me of my favorite fall
when the soul lies down in that grass
the world is too full to talk about
but you see it
is seeking you huh that's what's on the
bangle see you got one baby
it's aisha grandma we've met her thanks
to me yeah it's good you have us here
koi
i'd be lost
thank you
thank you for making a home for me here
[Laughter]
she looks at you as though your magic
[Music]
i take it she's never mentioned anything
about the actual bengal yet not the week
yeah kids playing with it seems bold
yeah
there's an action scene out there but
not yet
[Music]
i feel bad for telling the directors
that this was a feel-good show
[Laughter]
i mean
they had to have known we hadn't seen
much
don't you want to go home
i sure
of course i do
but i hit the bangle for safekeeping
retrieving it will take some time that
baby has a strong grip
you have until sundown tomorrow
and then we will all go
together
trustworthy smile so this lady's had the
same plan for generations just trying to
make it work we can take our memories
with us
so long as we are together we can build
a home anywhere hassan
what you seek is seeking you
that's what's on the bengal oh
new adventures can be scary i need you
to hold on to this for me
this will keep you safe
wherever you go
okay
remember that asgard is not a place it's
a people
[Music]
so is kamala witnessing all this right
now i'm assuming she's going to come in
but i'm surprised she hasn't been like
at the village or anything yet
oh they'll probably meet at the train
station who's that woman you're talking
to last night
i need to show you something
[Music]
but why are you telling me now because
you're running away
you asked
you have to trust me with this husband
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh no
[Music]
oh come on
[Music]
god what a nightmare
[Music]
got chills from that damn
[Music]
so she's magic even without the bangle
yeah i think the bangle is gonna be a
way for her to fine-tune it i'm assuming
yeah i think it's in her actual dna
yeah like it's passed down
anger
it brought you back to me
i'm not son if you don't have much time
get sun on the tree then protect that
bangle
you have
everything that should be whoa she is
the one that's how it all oh
yes called it
she used to say nanny like the story
she's okay
because you are here
[Music]
[Applause]
that's trippy what you seek is seeking
you through time is really cool
[Music]
come on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's a
mind trip
[Music]
ready and go
[Music]
this is so moving
damn
oh little one
[Music]
cool
[Music]
time travel can have some confusing
rules but it works
we think
now go back in time and kill baby hitler
oh my that doesn't seem good
[Music]
it's open
[Music]
i mean she's still not home
you know
magnum got lost once i had him my
crotchet
magnum is a dog the mala is a girl
microchipper anyway and just log into
your account and use the find my phone
feature to see where she is like like
spyware for parents kind of then why am
i only just hearing about this
not yet you can't
oh
who's come running
was to be with her family and you took
that from her
please don't take that from comrade too
oh okay
[Music]
damn
oh no
what have you done
what are you doing
[Laughter]
[Music]
our family is magical
and those lights how did that happen
i don't know but i like to think
two people fell in love and created
something
much bigger than either of them would
have created alone
oh that's beautiful i actually have one
more thing i need to do but i'll be
right back really quick just one
[Music]
and i'm pretty sure pakistani governs
the opposite of an irish one
you know if you ever need anything i'm
just take all the way although the us
government may or may not have several
warrants out for my arrest
for you
what is this
it broke
oh my god who is that who is that
that's your mother at your age no oh no
[Music]
oh
nice
she ran away when she was 17 to follow
that star um
it was
bon jovi
why have i never heard of this well
because you have never asked that's a
very specific question
[Laughter]
did you ever run away from
growing up
roughly 17
i couldn't see what you needed me to see
okay i'm sorry
name it uh
you saw exactly what you needed to see
at the right time
now let's get some coronas
family family
what is this sir we're back what is this
what is this some kind of america what
are we doing
i don't know where else to go
[Music]
you just keep helping everyone out man
bruno's a nice guy brian coy
does your car guy as well
can we just restart because this is
really weird uh
it's nice to meet you
i'm quran
yeah bruno oh my god i
genuinely thought your name was brian
this whole time oh no i had no notice
the first four times that
and i'm not gonna leave you to deal with
damage control yourself so you're good
we'll just stay here we'll figure it out
well i don't know if you're hungry but
my known is out of town she left some
lasagna oh no oh
[Music]
interesting array of shots there that
episode was fast was it
well like it was very front loaded like
the drama was two-thirds it just that
felt like 20 minutes and then the last
act was like it just felt like yeah i
thought it would be a half and half or
yeah
you guys are negative
that's right man
fastest about my mom
don't try to spin your criticism
that went by quickly and i enjoyed it
why are you so negative greg alba of the
internet you see all those young
avengers and secret wars connections
crazy
they're just building so much
why doesn't kamala just come right out
and say like that was me mom not meant
to
it's got to be a mystery
i would do it what if she tells you made
me feel like [ __ ] for so long mom
and you wouldn't be here
not how wounds heal
it's got to be mysterious yeah she's
probably still processing you sons of
[ __ ] georgia
all right guys
[Music]
you want to tell me why you took those
cory just said i thought we were going
to talk
so let me take off my talking efforts
[Laughter]
see if you can read my lips for this
review
no we were going to talk not for them
that we'd catch
[Laughter]
yeah why aren't you guys throwing
headphones down on the floor do we need
microphones
to speak guys one in the morning
here we are it's 12 40.
yeah cool
[Music]
dane cook shoes
gotta have coops getting the bk lounge
bleeding from the ears
swashing a dish i was washing a dish
that's not what he told me came outside
trunks
[Laughter]
mccall
all righty
well that was a very touching episode so
much warm hearts so much touchiness let
me even gesture micro there you go there
we go
you're too much background but yeah yeah
i quite enjoyed that one
um
i loved uh i actually loved the first
half way more than the last i mean i
like the reveal of seeing kamala was the
one who actually saved the great grandma
i thought that was really cool she
followed the stars grandma followed the
stars like she always remembered but the
stars but isn't it
time paradox
it also completely undermines everything
and gained a time travel establishment
time travel variances and it undermines
a lot of the tva probability because the
tva is all about splitting timelines and
having the true timeline exist implies
that there can be no pruning in this
version of time travel it's very com
like it doesn't work just two minutes
ago this guy was saying he wasn't
negative maybe that's an isolated loop
maybe maybe there's a nexus event maybe
kamal is the nexus level b but what
would someone think would have to have
happened for the great grandma to have
first got in a way to have
the grandma that had the mom that had
kamala for kamala to go back there so
i'm like what originally saved her in
the first place guys what you seek seeks
you
greg whatever that which you seek seeks
you she
set out to be like someone will say i
don't get how kyle reese is great father
of john connor it's very it's very much
that it's very confusing
but we're ignoring all the time travel
questions aside
that was very
beautiful and i felt like did you guys
see that coming i didn't see it coming
did you see it come the grandma thing
yeah yeah now whatever i said it on the
last episode do you think i pay
attention to what you're saying no i'm
literally focused right now on this file
excellent true he's going well
he's going to get up and he's going to
end it again we're going to have to talk
about his chair like he's not looking
forward to it right now i'm doing it
like he isn't here i'm looking forward
to komron and bruno bonding however i
suspect that bruno will get arrested
again by the dodc
i like that i didn't pick up those the
drones that are from uh
mysterio hey [ __ ] yeah
right there in front of me you suck i
pieced together the time travel but not
the visual cue you do know that people
are gonna comment
i can't believe you didn't pick up on
the mysterio drones
mention it five minutes after they
appeared in the reaction yep because
they already clicked off and said this
guy doesn't know what he's talking about
he's not a comic book expert do you guys
think that was pterogenesis
what's he talking about see there it is
definitely looks like other mcu i'll say
adjacent representations of how terror
genesis works because if you're a
regular human you walk into that
pterogenesis mist coming out of that
weird portal oh yeah the original thing
that gave kamal a power yeah i'm
wondering if there is an inhuman name
drop in the next episode there could be
i'm i'm quite curious i mean it would
seem
the trouble for me with that is that it
would seem as though uh
i don't know like they're all using
powers of nur anyway so
uh
part of me wonders if that could in any
way possibly be some kind of
pterogenesis
i guess to be if it's stereogenesis it
would have to be a wholly new phenomenon
and so whatever the veil is and whatever
it does
then can't be whatever gave them the
power or or is the key to the power in
the first place maybe it's keeping the
telogenesis in maybe maybe they develop
something to protect it or like to to
contain it what part are you talking
about uh the sequence right as um
the the great grandma no the as the gram
as as comrade's mom
goes through when she gets like bricked
and like turned into a skull yeah yeah
that looks a lot like the representation
of when a regular human gets terror
genesis and like dies i think you're
being too hopeful
it could
be i don't think that's gonna happen
here you know what i can dream i'd be
very surprised that opens up a whole new
door and i think they're they gotta keep
some of this focused so that way you
know miss marvel can come in in the
post-credits scene or something like
that
actually i'm going to throw that down
right now i'd imagine not at the camera
marvel oh captain marvel i imagine that
captain marvel is going to come in the
are you going uh photon or or og
uh oh gee i'm everyone loves
larson's gonna show up all right and 50
of the internet's gonna yell at their
screen yeah
white america
do you have an msr that could be one
yeah
little erica
just like this
uh
yeah i think that's gonna happen and um
marshall mather's cameo yeah marshall
love marvel he does love references a
lot of comics
man oh marvel mathers that's the
superhero we need well i think i mean as
we were talking about during the
reaction what i imagine is is that
it's not as they show with a great
grandma that the bengal is merely some
type of
i mean i liken it to sort of like
mjolnir
in it with thor in a way
how thor was like
all my power comes from the mjolnir but
then at the end he realizes that's not
the real source of his power which is
why i'm wondering about that
humans thing because she does seem to
have magic jesus christ let it go i want
it
i want it it's not gonna happen
that is what i imagine but i really
respect this show for like i love that
at the very beginning of this they went
all out with 25 minutes of just bold
dramatic storytelling like beautiful but
even with like the his that look like
real archive footage yeah i'm sure some
of it was the war and such and uh that
it has to be mixed in with it and i
really appreciate that they did that
because i'm like i'm learning so much
right now yeah i didn't know most of
that and and you know that's that's part
of our public school system here but
also you know some things are
we're not as exposed to in pop culture
so it's really beautiful for something
with as big of a platform as marvel to
be like let's educate you for three
minutes and then tie it integrally into
this specific bottle episode like
usually bottle episodes are like a slang
like a negative slang like this was
bottled in that was contained but it was
one of the most informative episodes of
tv for this time and event well yeah and
they also
kept what what i really respect about
what they did with this episode in
particular is i mean i i was pretty
attached to the great grandparents
pretty fast you go yeah pop that in john
i was pretty attached to the great
grandparents pretty fast like super
early on wouldn't you agree john john's
terror genesis oh my god i'm on this
side of the building
now i'm on the other side
because he's not really here but we're
talking like he's here yeah john's
figuring it out
john how are your powers activated was
it the mists
yeah you can say that yeah i could say
that
greg wouldn't believe this is so
hilarious you see the generation for the
podcast this is what they need they
enjoy a good visual visual joke the
podcast is hilarious i'm just ending
cory here we are oh man so i think
learning improv here this is the moment
it's happening live it's happening
give us a location
starbucks oh
give us an unlikely scenario
you burnt the cookie dough oh no i burnt
the cookie dough with the starbucks t
yes handed so fast he put that together
with the speed and efficiency of a
seasoned veteran next stop laugh factory
he's coming up next
yeah
anyway
was but yeah but but they they got me
really connected to those characters
like
very very fast surprisingly that i
stopped thinking about kamala khan yeah
very early on and i was so invested in
this and for this show that is
constantly talking about you know
inheritance and generations and lineage
and all these things
it was nice to actually go
way back and not just see like a
five-minute flashback
but truly
spend time with
the upheaval battles and the struggles
that they've had to go through that
where this all really stems from and
when this journey really began of
fighting against uh
what's her name horacing oh what's the
lady's name the bad clandestine
cameron's mom amron's mom it's like
nejma or something like that yeah yeah
normally we count on you jonathan yeah
oh yeah he's gonna banff again oh my god
oh where are you guys invisible
what's the name of them
give us the location you give us an ugly
scenario disneyland oh
that's unique you never hear that never
hear that one uh a speed bump uh pops a
tire
oh mickey
is that your mickey
i like that you made a voice say that
made eye contact with me and you were
like nope do that that's not it yeah
anyway john tell us why you cried again
najma oh uh yeah i mean i i appreciated
i don't know any time that there is just
a din of chaos and everyone is very
desperate and people get separated like
i don't know that's just a movie motif
that really works when they can uh you
know draw it
it's in the filmmaking it's in the
context it's all that stuff and yeah i
thought that the sort of i found a
beauty in as much as we are sitting here
going how did the mechanics work i found
a beauty in that sort of loop around and
the fact that yeah like there's all this
sci-fi stuff happening but at the same
time you're also dealing with something
very primal just people trying
to get safe transport out of a bad
situation and yeah like there's just so
much
emotion there to me and so yeah like
this i remember saying the last episode
like oh man it ends on this note where
you're transported back and i hope that
they'll spend you know a good amount of
time and they did kind of what i was
hoping they would do in this episode you
know um
present day uh you know coda aside
uh yeah i just thought it was
like as much as there is world building
and there is plot building and stuff in
all of that flashback as much as you
know there are way more educational
things you could watch i thought they
struck a a good balance between the
harsh reality of the situation this
little intimate story between these two
people and then the sort of surrounding
chaos and circumstances and yeah there
was something cathartic when kamala
finally meets back up with that and she
has to i think too
like right now in this moment of
superhero anything i think whenever
anybody uh whenever they depict
the helping or saving of someone
innocent and helpless that also really
strikes me because you know there are
concessions made to that you know like
there's a fun like oh i caught some
people and i saved them and i'm running
off again and it's like a really quick
thing whereas this was like living in
that moment of just
you know save this one little girl and
yeah it was very funny i like that all
the emotional build up was also story
build up so the stars and the the the
inscription on the like all of it tied
into that one moment and it was while
our emotions were peak like all of the
story landed right as we're as
emotionally invested as we can possibly
be because i was so immediately invested
in the other family too and i didn't
expect to be uh like when we met them i
was like okay and then within you know
five minutes so by the time we got to
that point i cared so much about that
little girl i cared so much about all
these things but then the plot came back
in because they'd laid that groundwork
and then kamala was able to move the
plot forward and then like just some of
the framing choices like when she's with
her her mom and grandma and they're the
frame in front of all the picture frames
and you see family and then you see
generations of family so you've got
three generations of family and then
other generations of family as you pull
back like little details like that
really just enhanced the already very
family heavy story and i've been
thinking about it in the last five
minutes maybe
the timeline didn't have to get pruned
because it was always destined that she
would loop back on the timeline so
theoretically it wouldn't be a prune
timeline because it never created an
alternate so theoretically that could
loop and that would be a way that it
wouldn't sacrifice endgame's continuity
wouldn't alert the tva and wouldn't
cause any continuity issues because it's
always meant to be
a loop of course so self-absorber you
guys can't see but he's looking at
himself this whole time i was seeing my
loop
so we have a little monitor here in
front of us and he's just still what's
up mine this whole time he's been
looking at himself while he's talking
how am i looking on camera right now
that face how am i looking on camera
yeah no i think it's great and
especially with everything you guys are
talking about i think what's beautiful
about it is that throughout the
generations what's kept them preserved
is love yeah fighting for love the
entire time i think that's
wonderful like family message
to bring along and uh because as much as
this like explores you know some
generational trauma there's always been
love throughout it that has kept them
all bonded and has kept them literally
alive throughout all this and her family
being about like
always seeking
to stay together always staying together
no matter what and then comrade's mom
like abandoning him and then possessing
him or whatever that just happened like
that is an interesting dichotomy as well
for the for the potential of those two
characters and even for kamala khan who
we started off in this season of of her
show of being like kind of
uh you know ambivalent with her family
and kind of kind of want to go her own
path and do her own thing and now she's
finding her true strength by embracing
her family history embracing her family
i think that's actually quite beautiful
so yeah and with comrade
i mean all right prediction time it's
going to go down okay okay come here
who's the guy who's the red dagger guy
come here kareem kareem yeah i was
remembering those spellings
uh kareem kareem yeah i think kareem's
gonna go back with them
to the united states oh yeah i don't
think that was his last appearance i
don't think it's last minute i think
he's gonna go back with him to you ass
kevin and i'm bang bang it out so it's
some clandestine action what's going on
with the cam comrade i mean okay
is spoilers isn't spoiled i don't really
give a [ __ ] for me personally but do you
yeah like is it light spoilers yeah in
the comic books she has some powers
they not look exactly like the ones
they've depicted are they like miss
marvels they seem very similar well
what's funny is
her powers are like his like in the
comments her powers are different so yes
presentation oh that's fascinating so it
is it's like the loop of the tva and the
thrones and everything you said earlier
it's all happening
thanks greg i agree
validation
but i i do think they've they've kind of
nailed that look without it looking like
iceman because sometimes in the comments
you could easily look like a frost boy
um so i think they nailed that i i am
curious about uh that last shot that
that strange edit of like circle q is
exploding and then we we you know we
exited out i i get you need to leave
that on a cliffhanger like you need to
leave there but uh it's certainly a it
was a bold uh
kodo to be like you got two minutes do
all of this storytelling
yeah because the episode was shorter so
it was it was just interesting that we
didn't get like you know more of a 10
minute 30 minute like 30 minutes in the
past and then 10 minutes to like get us
cozy again but that jarringness may work
for the pace maybe the next episode's
got a lot more going on and it's a
faster tone so beyond
all that fun stuff we talked about brie
larson shows up where bree larson shows
the x-men show up john krasinski is read
written
yeah yeah
the real question is
which one of the three boys
is kamala gonna choose john you go first
that's what's important it's gonna be
red dagger oh coy none of them because
she is going to be teaming up with
strong independent women and she don't
need a man
i agree what a load up
crock of [ __ ]
all three they're all hanging up the
side of their best friend's right
they're trying to holler out this is the
show
pioneer polyamorous relationships yes
miss marvel
gonna duke it out with all them guys
duke it out
it's a peachy so concern uh no i think
uh i i say i think bruno he could do
some cool stuff with those powers i
think i think it would lie actually i
think her
going with bruno and the dagger lines up
so much and bruno's i'm gonna get this
point through you watched uh
lines up so much with her character arc
so far of realizing that everything
she's ever loved and everything she's
ever needed is right here with her
already very articulate and having with
the the love of her family has been in
front of her the whole time that gives
her the most strength and the power
within and bruno is the one who's always
been there not these other two
dweebs handsome fellas
heroes storyline not you
talented skilled athletic men
is bruno
bruno who's ducky uh this is not a sp
okay mild spoiler if you don't want to
know anything but mild spoilers skip
ahead 20 seconds uh in the comic books
gets in an accident and loses an arm uh
i'm wondering if he loses an arm in this
explosion and he has to design like a
tech arm the star wars thingy yeah
marvel does marvel loves the arm blocks
but in the comic books he gets a
wakandan arm so it'd be kind of cool to
see iron heart which is an upcoming show
riggery williams wakanda into that stuff
that is how bruno knows that world if he
loses his arm in this then we later see
riri introduced cause she's got a show
maybe that's how we meet her and then
winter soldier trains bruno ri-ray by
the way is not a wakandan but she uses
wakandan tech later on the issues uh
williams is an mit kid that tony stark
mentors and then becomes the voice of in
her own helmet and it's kind of like
this father-daughter relationship
thought you were a racist
i
i hope not
i don't know no one in there thank you
oh he's just a little bit this was riri
exists that that means that that is uh
wakandan girl everyone's from no one was
thinking you were thinking that no black
people well now they did that's what i'm
clarifying oh thanks to help you out to
protect you that's good because i
certainly wasn't because otherwise
that'd be problematic guys pakistan is
in south asia
everyone needs to know that i mean
according to the commentary but i i
think we all learn more about that world
in the opening of this and then we got
to invest with brand new characters yeah
i think that like of the marvel shows
this
20-minute chunk was maybe the most have
been invested in individual characters
that were new yeah like obviously loki i
care about loki and all those things and
i love what they do with mobius but like
as far as just a little 20 minute like
family that was so in yeah it was
beautiful
it helps that they're very attractive
actors i mean
that's cinema
that is cinema and stage in many ways
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right guys well we're done with
talking about miss marvel permanently
let's see which predictions come true
does she end up with the red dagger boy
does she end up with comrade does she
end up with bruno nakia all the single
ladies all
wandering single ladies for all our
minds and hearts are at so good asian
and human like over under and then
captain marvel shows up for terror no
logical reason
i think she's inhuman i think they say
it
fine last episode yes greg agrees with
me i heard it here first folks
john i'm for it i would like an inhumans
uh call out please
what if you just see like
[Music]
the the mist and then it ends and you
got to deal with inhumans in the captain
marvel movie you got the budget you got
black bolt here so in humans exactly
that's what i'm saying at least in a
timeline in universe eight three eight
but if this is a loop and this is
theoretically the sacred timeline to the
tva come and deal with all those
shenanigans coy gets paid by the minute
maybe the north spanning this route
maybe
crystal's here i keep saying it no money
no problems
all right cory before you go we should
end this with a patron
coy you ever been to atlanta i have it's
where the players play and the party
don't stop like every day okay well uh
hotlantaga our buddy eric horstmann a
man who has been having some health
struggles as of late i've made it a goal
to go to atlanta this year oh to go
visit my family recently moved to the
land you can stay with my family they
want to meet you they're they're awesome
moms they're going to stay in the other
room nice you call her huh
hey hot mom it's hot sun coy
that's why i look at myself i hope
you're having a hot day but eric is in
atlanta
eric has been one of a
first and foremost eric this is most
important to acknowledge
one of our highest pledges for years now
that's where the value of our friendship
literally monitors look at it literally
that's how we establish the rapport here
is based off of that yeah
excellent also by the word excellent
work my friend secondly um he's the only
one in this entire world who has a real
rejects tattoo oh that's incredible he
has a big it's a big tattoo and and
here's the kicker we changed the logo
since he got the tattoo so it's classic
only a crew valve
i've also never heard his last name
that's a cool last name horstmann yeah i
know
before everything got censored on
youtube and you say one word like
demonetized
um so yeah and uh he's also just the
sweetest guy like every once in a while
i hit him up it's very rare but once in
a while just hit him up on the phone
there's a uh there's a there's an in and
out esque restaurant called varsity and
i do chili on their hot dogs and burgers
and it's kind of like the atlanta
version of like it's like you know you
go to like people come to l.a they're
like i gotta hang out varsity is the
atlanta version delicious we'll all go
oh okay i'm trying to make this shout
out about eric horsley
and you're making this about atlanta
but eric's coming back because we're
gonna go to atlanta you know what my
favorite donald glover series
definitely atlanta great show called
ludacris also from atlanta oh wow yeah
guys they shoot most things in it eric
is also from atlanta
this episode was shot in it in georgia
yeah so
tyler perry studios
in atlanta eric horseman was a pa on ms
marvel could have been with his tattoo
eric um he works at a hotel i won't say
which one not get him in trouble that's
very smart but he might be able to help
us out stay there
that's the idea yes
in atlanta i was going with that i see i
see hey eric we're going to florida can
you put this up a hotel i probably could
with his job actually at that hotel
but eric um thank you for
being loyal those for so long and i just
want to say too
that if anything terrible were to ever
happen to you if you were to pass on in
some way
can you make sure your credit card stays
on file and that way the pledge just
keeps going through every month i hope
in your will
that that's what you have there
is that
all my money
goes to the real rejects patreon and
whoever is in charge of your state like
when the card expires you got to renew
it that's yes that's that's that's
that's it's got to be part of it i mean
it's right i think long term you got it
this isn't just a couple years just put
all your assets into one account and
then let that just you know
we shut down the patreon yeah
you've just get the money wired directly
to my
credit union and and it's got to be in
pieces like when you're in the lottery
you get the choice of like do you want
it at once
gotta be over the top because greg will
frankly put it up his name
[Music]
eric would appreciate that darkness of
humor don't don't comment blow sensitive
waiter is everyone going to see this i
thought it was just for him everyone
yeah this is the part video
it's at the end of the video to these in
the video just to see that and yeah i
just didn't think you did the whole
thing i've seen the patron shout outs i
just didn't realize you unedited just
just this is gonna be unedited oh okay
this is just how i'm not editing this
five minute shout out where four and a
half minutes is about atlanta
it's a great city
delicious delicious varsity first we're
done
bye eric great last name tattoo and all
[Music]
you